Вадим Селезньов хоче змінитися
заради свого нового життя. Для цього хлопець
наполегливо тренується. Спорт для Вадима - це
спосіб назавжди поставити крапку на минулому.
- Я викрав автомобіль і потрапив в аварію.
Звісно, втік з місця події.
Потім, через деякий час… два дні минуло…
мене поліцейські впіймали.
Вже два роки Вадим Селезньов живе в інтернаті
для неповнолітніх злочинців у Серафимівці.
Молодь, що тут опинилася, мала проблеми
на свободі. Хлопці крали автівки, влаштовували бійки,
вживали наркотики і навіть убивали.
- На волі ця дитина становить загрозу для,
грубо кажучи, двадцяти дітей із класу.
З ним не знають, що робити. Із успішних сімей
вони прийшли чисто вдягнені, нагодовані,
вони знають, що вони підуть додому і на них чекатимуть батьки.
А от наші діти, наш контингент, вони приходять
у школу, в них, грубо кажучи, вдягти на себе нічого,
вони, звісно, вимушені вступити в конфлікт з іншими, успішними дітьми.
Обід. Вадим сьогодні чергує на кухні.
Їжі тут, схоже, вдосталь: суп, м'ясні страви, компот.
Бригада Вадима накриває столи.
Порядок спрощує життя в інтернаті.
Тут діють чіткі правила, яких треба дотримуватися,
і жорстка дисципліна.
(хором кажуть: "Спа-си-бо")
- Спочатку злим був. Постійно, коли був на волі, вдома,
ходив постійно, бійки влаштовував,
а сюди я приїхав і зовсім змінився.
Деякі вихованці інтернату - сироти.
У багатьох батьки - алкоголіки, наркозалежні чи
ув'язнені й позбавлені опікунських прав.
Вадим в інтернаті повинен "стати кращим".
"Кращим" у розумінні вчителів.
Ідеал - російський солдат.
- У нас єдині вимоги, єдині вимоги.
Заправка. Тут у нас конверт має бути, от.
Така заправка має бути і натягнуто,
натягнуто в такий спосіб. У нас школа для пацанів,
ми їх до армії готуємо.
Це не якась там така собі в'язниця.
І це спрацьовує. Багато хлопців із Серафимівки
справді йдуть в армію. Тут виховують
не критично мислячих вільних громадян Росії,
а патріотичних служителів держави,
які не піддають сумніву авторитет уряду.
Адже дітей тут навчають бути вдячними
за другий шанс і турботу.
Про вихованців турбуються вчителі.
Чимало з них переконані, що роблять щось хороше
для таких як Вадим, і, звісно, для держави.
- Від цих дітей є якась віддача ось цього тепла,
вони потребують, щоб їх по голові пожаліли
попри те, що йому 16 років, ось тому ж Вадиму.
Вони діляться своїми секретами.
І якщо вони діляться чимось таким потаємним,
то, мабуть, це довіра.
А заслужити довіру
від таких хлопців, як наші, це багато чого варте.
Будівля інтернату Серафимівки оточена
високим парканом, який має запобігти втечам.
Але звідси й так практично ніхто не намагається втекти, каже Вадим.
- Три місяці побув я тут. Коли вже адаптувався,
мене почали відпускати за межі школи на прогулянку.
В мене навіть думки не промайнуло, щоб утекти,
тому що тут добре до тебе ставляться.
Від заснування інтернату в Серафимівці
в 1970-х роках через нього пройшли багато молодих хлопців.
Вони походять із навколишніх куточків
російської республіки Башкортостан.
Кожен великий регіон Росії має такі школи для перевиховання.
- Якби було так, щоб ці діти лишалися в наших стінах...
Але, на превеликий жаль, я не скажу,
що це на щастя, на жаль, через три роки діти йдуть.
І вони, буває, повертаються в те саме середовище,
з якого вони пішли. Ті хлопці,
в яких утворився якийсь стрижень у спецшколі,
вони - так, вони можуть вже йти якимось шляхом.
Діти, що потрапляють у Серафимівку,
швидко розуміють, що для декого життя
за парканом простіше, ніж на волі.
Поєднання дисципліни та турботи - нетипове
для російської судової системи, з якою хлопці,
як Вадим, рано познайомились.
І, можливо, тут теж спалахують великі конфлікти.
Утім, поки ми перебували тут із камерою, їх не було видно.
Натомість - державний ідеал російського інтернату для перевиховання.